[Music]
they have so much in common with other
American families everybody's mad at
everybody so we'll find a way through
and hopefully other people will too
ABC is hoping to keep that relatability
on TV just without Roseanne Barr after
acting the revived sitcom last month in
the wake of that racist tweet scandal a
source tells et the network and
producers are deep in discussions about
a new spin up centered on a different
Conner family member our source says
Roseanne will not be compensated in any
way should a new show make it to air a
big question mark up until now as she
was credited with creating the
characters a separate source close to
production tells et that Roseanne has
spent recent days calling cast and some
crew in an effort to quote try and make
things right
Roseanne she called me Jeeva our source
says Roseanne has told the people she's
calling she's a mortified to think her
on-screen granddaughter Jaden ray thinks
she doesn't love her because of the
color of her skin
although the producers aren't sure who
would be central to the new version of
the show it seems certain that Roseanne
herself will not be coming back
[Applause]
you